welcome to this DW business special I'm
Rob watts in Berlin and today we're
asking if Europe is de-industrializing
European factories have been shutting
down furnaces and keeping production to
a minimum why because of the soaring
cost of energy the war in Ukraine has
driven up the prices of oil and gas and
energy intensive Industries are the
first to feel the pinch with no end in
sight for Europe's power problems could
a phase out of factories beyond the
cards
or to answer that question and many more
I'm joined by Maria de mertzis the
deputy director of Brussels based
economic Think Tank brugal Maria welcome
to the program and just to kick straight
off
um what do we mean when we talk about
de-industrialization
bigger a bit actually a smaller role in
the economy and I think when people talk
about that process they typically refer
to Industry as reducing the amount of
people it employs so it's more of a
labeled in the industrialization rather
than the contribution of the industries
in the economy in general
is there also an aspect to it about you
know economies producing less of the raw
materials that they use as well
it actually uses raw materials to
produce a particular good so we import
typically the raw materials from
elsewhere as Europe does not really have
raw materials and we use those uh to
produce manufacturing or other things
and one of the biggest one is of course
energy which of course at the moment is
particularly problematic
well I think just to understand how
significant de-industrialization would
be for Europe it's worth to just look at
how big a role it plays in European
economies and a good way to do that is
by looking at what percentage of gross
domestic product comes from industry
currently firstly in Europe's industrial
Powerhouse Germany it makes up over a
fifth that's above the average for the
EU of 16.5 percent and over in the US
industry makes up a smaller share of GDP
than it does in Europe I mean while in
the UK which has shed much of its
industry it now accounts for just a
tenth of GDP so Maria domensis is
industry uh too big a part of the
European economic system to be lost
well absolutely I think if the industry
were going to disappear that would be as
your numbers show uh that that would be
a big hit for the European economy but I
think the process of the
industrialization is not one of of
Disappearing make the industry disappear
is smart it's more about shares a new
Industries need to come in that I'm
thinking in particular of the digital uh
part of the of the economy as they come
in they also claim parts of the shares
of the economy but that doesn't
necessarily mean that the big
manufacturer in Europe will disappear
it's just that the shares will be
replaced
right so if industry does go you talk
about
digitalization for example being
something that would replace it but but
are there other sectors that would also
have to to step in as well
well I think the one big issue that
needs to be resolved still is how we're
going to Green the economy and and no
doubt many Industries and no doubt also
in new Industries will have to come in
and and contribute to the uh to the
growth of the economy and actually help
us achieve the very ambitious objectives
that we have for 2050. so I think the
the issue here is how we're going to
Green our Industries and what types of
new Industries do we need to create in
order for economy to uh to continue to
thrive
the current reduction in industrial
activity particularly in places like
Germany was not planned it's quite
sudden it's a result of you know what's
been happening in Ukraine and with
relations with Russia so can those other
sectors that would need to step into a
place industry can they can they do that
quickly enough
well I think we need to differentiate
and the longer term the longer terms I
think the industrialization is is a
process of a longer term Trends what is
happening now is a reaction to the
inability to meet our energy needs the
issues that you refer to have to do with
the fact that the energy bill is too
high but also for the with the fact that
we need to reduce our energy consumption
in next winter otherwise we won't meet
we don't have enough energy to go around
so the industry that is shutting out
right now is simply because it cannot
continue not because there is an
underlying Trend that implies that in
the long run it will not survive so I
think we need to differentiate the two
and deal with the two very differently
okay well let's deal firstly then with
the with the near term and let's get an
idea of the pressure that's facing
European industry right now here's what
the heads of some of the continents
manufacturers have had to say about the
current state of play
between January 2021 and January 2023
the price of electricity will have been
multiplied by 22 and gas by 18. in these
conditions our production lines are
worthless if you maintain production our
energy costs could represent up to 40
percent of our turnover which is
untenable
[Music]
I think we urgently need a europe-wide
industrial electricity price that would
stabilize the situation for our industry
but of course that's not something you
can develop and roll out within a couple
of weeks so it's not going to work
unless there's emergency AIDS
this is actually up to now there's been
no support at all from the state we've
applied for support for the high energy
prices but the application was extremely
bureaucratic and it almost seems as if
obstacles were being deliberately put in
the way so that as few companies as
possible could receive support
foreign
industry leaders there complaining that
they're not getting enough help I mean
if we have this longer term trend of
de-industrialization is it really in the
interest of governments now to
step in and try to prevent this shorter
term thing that we are seeing
maintain we are going to kill otherwise
productive firms and that's not how you
would generate how that's not how you
diversify your industry
um I think what we've heard in the in
the in the little comments it has to do
with the fact that the energy bill is so
high that the energy the current
industry cannot meet uh its uh its
energy needs and it cannot pay for the
bill
um there are many ways of helping
Industries in the current juncture
including uh by changing the way that
energy is priced now as we correctly
heard also this is not something that we
could do
immediately however I think there is
emergency measures that the European
commission and others are thinking about
to try and help companies sustain the
energy crisis as we see today part of it
will necessarily have to be a direct
support to the firms but how we do this
exactly of course remains to be seen I
remind you also that we just come out of
the pandemic where exactly the same
needs arose there
um the Khan used all countries in the
European Union raised up to the occasion
and actually helped the industry in
order not to go bankrupt now it is true
also that the help that still countries
have at hand namely the fiscal means to
do so is now reduced but in any case I'm
sure that there will be ways of helping
industry to uh to at least survive in
the next year or so
yeah and and the way that should be
approached is by going directly to
Industry and trying to help them out or
is it a broader energy policy that needs
to be introduced across Europe
well we're having both so we have and
but my view is that the more targeted
the help is the better a better it is
because it reaches the needy when it
comes to the households for example it
really is the the the the households
that represent the low-income households
that require more help with meeting the
energy bills and when it comes to firms
also not all firms have been hit the
same way as you had said earlier on the
energy intensive firms have been hit
very high uh right now because the
energy bill obviously for them is
exorbitant and therefore targeting that
support is always very helpful now
there's a trade-off here if you want to
do it quickly then it's easier to just
give everybody something but if you want
to do it well then you need to take the
time and find out who is the one who
needs the help the most and then Target
it appropriately
okay Marie I'll be back with you in a
moment but there are those arguing that
keeping industry alive when it's no
longer cost effective is a waste of time
and resources here's the view of
Christian buyer an economics professor
at the University of Bonn here in
Germany
in a situation like this winter where we
have a shortage of resources it makes no
sense to keep energy intensive
Industries artificially in production
quite simply because energy is extremely
scarce
therefore it makes sense to do without
energy intensive production right now
because the energy is needed more
urgently elsewhere
foreign
ER is part of the problem for our
industry that when you've got problems
like you know very high inflation very
high energy bills that actually they're
not that high up the priority list for
governments particularly when households
are suffering
well no it's a there is some some truth
in that however I think it's important
that we sustain the industries because
they're the ones who employ uh uh the uh
the households in any case you know we
need to find ways of protecting the the
fiber of the economy otherwise there's
going to be erosions that there will be
very difficult to regenerate afterwards
so that their balance is to be struck
here and there are measures of taxing
those who have made exorbitant profits
during the energy crisis and use those
funds to distribute those more than need
it both households as well as firms that
are actually essential for the
productive fiber of the economy
but is what you're arguing they're
actually taking money from industry to
ease the problems elsewhere in the
economy
beside actually that have made
exorbitant profits during this crisis
and simply because there are
particularities in the way that energy
prices are being dictated and and there
is a lot of talk and a lot of sympathy
for taxing those exorbitant profits and
use those funds to help those firms that
actually have suffered during the energy
crisis and indeed households
right yeah so so any any Aid to
um industry and indeed any I suppose the
opposite of aid but taking money from
industry needs to be targeted need to be
done a case-by-case basis Marie I'll be
back with you again in a second one of
the problems as I've just mentioned
facing manufacturers in places like
Germany is that they're not the
government's priority when it comes to
energy so if you take a look at this
chart of Germany's energy distribution
you can see that German households
transport as well and services all need
a lot of energy too the most energy
intensive industrial sectors are
particularly vulnerable to high energy
prices the ones listed here account for
three quarters of Germany's industrial
energy usage
so Maria demetz is that's the situation
in Germany but there are some European
countries better positioned to whether
this assault on the continent's energy
intensive Industries than others
certainly in terms of meeting the energy
demands simply because of the uh the
energy is generated differently in
different countries those who rely a lot
on gas no doubt are suffering right now
because gas prices are exorbitant others
who have a better a more Diversified
Energy Mix they can actually meet the
energy demands however I will say that
the price of energy is a rather bizarre
animal that is being formed in European
markets and that of course means that
all countries face very high prices
irrespective of how energy is being
generated so in that respect everybody
suffers the differences of the
quantities are not on the price
is this an example of Germany missing
out because of its over-reliance on
Russian energy for the past decade
I think the end
of the ending when you put all your eggs
in one basket then you become vulnerable
to that basket breaking I think it's uh
the one thing that we learned from the
calendar crisis is the diversification
is uh including in energy sources is
absolutely essential and that of course
is something that we will fix it's just
that we can't do it immediately
so that's the short term as we said we
need to differentiate between
de-industrialization in the short term
and in the long term we're clearly
seeing some short-term effects but are
we on the route to Europe
de-industrializing or at least industry
playing a significantly smaller role in
Europe's economy
because I think that is going to be the
one thing to solve uh rather urgently
and no doubt we will need new
technologies we will need new ways of
creating energies that are clean they
will contribute to the industrial fabric
of the economy and they will replace
other industries that will become
obsolete so that is the first thing to
do then of course there is other trends
that are going on we talked about them
earlier the issue of digitalization for
example digitalization is absolutely
essential and there is one way to travel
to travel that is more digitalization in
non-industries and that of course
requires new industry being created now
again how well Europe will manage to get
into this wagon of digitalization
depends on many things including Finance
but I think that the term
de-industrialization is perhaps not fair
to the to the fact that new Industries
will have to be created and and they
will be part of a new industry that is
greener more digital and and actually
quite different from the heavy industry
that we knew from uh from the past uh
all of this is in the process of
happening uh and and that's why I think
I will the you know the jury is still
out as whether that inquire requires a
de-industrialization of Simply a
different industrialization
I think what people might be wondering
and certainly I I'm wondering is if
Europe
relies Less on its own industry and
presumably the industry of Elsewhere in
the world we saw the frailties of Global
Supply chains during the course of the
pandemic you know what happens in one
country can have a huge impact on what
happens on the product in terms of
production elsewhere so how do you
square the idea of de-industrializing
Europe as we're phrasing it with that
problem with the fact that Global Supply
chains are you know offshoring it's
actually uh something that over the last
couple of years we've learned is not
necessarily the best thing to do
again I think the the key word here is
diversification so you know the longer
the supply chains and the over-reliance
on just one particular supply chain that
is very long makes the industry
vulnerable to that supply chain breaking
this is what we've learned in the past
few years actually with both crisis for
different reasons diversify and
therefore robustify the industry that
necessarily means that some of the
chains will have to be uh shorter and
there will be you know not relying on
just one input but on many different
inputs geographical inputs in order to
avoid uh this the uh the uh the
sensitivities that we saw I think I need
to say though that that would imply
higher cost
um because you know the process of
globalization meant that we went to
where cost where uh the lowest and
therefore we could produce in the most
cost effective uh way
um it's interesting to see that Supply
chains have actually not uh suffered as
a result of the two crises we've seen so
far but I think there is certainly a
real realization that we need to
robustify the systems and diversify my
sense is that some of the global Service
Supply chains will necessarily shorten
that will make the industry more robust
but I think at higher cost
okay Maria demetz is from the Brussels
based economic think tank brugal thank
you so much for joining us on the
program and for taking so much time out
just to answer those questions for us
and thanks also to you for watching
while uh you're here on YouTube why not
check out some of our other videos
including our other business specials of
course and also our series business
Beyond which is always well worth a
watch until next time take care